so that's forward stepwise selection um
and now we're briefly going to talk
about backward stepwise and backwards
stepwise is once again just like forward
it's an efficient alternative to best
subset selection but it actually is
exactly the opposite of forward stepwise
so remember in forward stepwise we built
the model m0 and then we added a feature
to get m1 added a feature to get m2
and in contrast for backward stepwise
we're going to start with mp
which is the model containing p
predictors and we're going to remove
predictors one at a time one at a time
until we get to m0 which is the model
with with just an intercept
so in a little more detail we start with
mp which is just the regular least
squares model if you just didn't do any
feature selection and you just wanted to
use all of your predictors
and then we're going to take that model
mp and we're going to consider removing
predictors one at a time
excuse me we're going to consider
removing each of the p predictors and
we're going to see which predictor is
the least useful to us which predictor
can we remove that's going to have the
the smallest
effect on either rss or r squared
so we're going to remove the least
useful predictor and that'll give us the
model mp minus one
and then we're going to take mp minus
one and we're gonna again ask which
predictor is the least useful which one
can we remove in order to have the least
detrimental effect on our our model fit
and we're gonna keep doing this until we
make it down to the model with just one
predictor m1 and finally to the model
with with no predictors which is m0
so that's once again going to give us a
set of models
from m0 to mp
and we're going to choose among them
using once again cross validation aic
bic or adjusted r squared
so just as was the case for forward
stepwise selection backward stepwise
considers around p squared models
instead of two to the p so it's a
fantastic computational alternative to
to best subset selection
especially when p is
is moderate or large
and actually the exact number of models
the backward selection considers you
know i've been saying it's around p
squared it's actually more like p
squared over two that's the exact
formula and that's a good thing to work
out at home so you know think about it
why is it that if you do forward
stepwise selection or backward step by
selection you're actually considering
this number of models
so just like forward stepwise selection
backward stepwise is not guaranteed to
give us the best model containing a
particular subset of the p predictors so
it was that same picture that rob draw
drew a few minutes ago where we saw that
forward stepwise for any given model
size might give a larger rss or
equivalently a smaller r squared than
best subset
so similarly backwards stepwise might
not give quite as good of a model in
terms of rss or r-squared
but that can still be okay and in the
long run it could give us better results
on a test set not to mention it's more
computationally efficient
so one major difference as we mentioned
between backward and forward stepwise is
that with backward stepwise we start
with the model containing all of the
predictors
so in order to be able to do that we
need to be in a situation where we have
more observations than variables
because remember we can do least squares
regression when n is greater than p
but if p is greater than n we cannot fit
a least squares model it's not even
defined
so we can only do backward selection
when n
is greater than p
and in contrast we can do forward
stepwise whether n is less than p
or n is greater than p
oops
so um
we mentioned that um
the model containing all of the
predictors is always going to have a
smaller r squared
excuse me the model containing all the
predictors is always going to have a
smaller rss
and a larger r squared than any other
model because these quantities are
really related to the training error
so again this is the picture that rob
drew
but if i think about fitting a model
with the number of predictors on the
y-axis
and rss on the
if i think about fitting a model with
number of predictors on the x-axis and
rss on the y-axis this is going to be
monotone decreasing
and similarly
if i think about a picture with number
of predictors on the x-axis and r
squared on the y-axis it's going to be
monotone increasing
so if i so remember we when we do best
subset or forward or backward step-wise
we end up with these models m0 through
mp
and i cannot just choose among them
using r squared or using rss because
i'll always choose the biggest model and
again that just boils down to the fact
that these quantities
are just based on the training error
but i want to model with low test error
because i wanted to do well on future
observations that i haven't seen like um
you know
patients who haven't walked into the
clinic yet for whom i'm going to want to
predict some sort of response
and unfortunately just choosing a model
with the best training error isn't going
to give me a model that has a low test
error because in general training error
is a really bad predictor of test error
a really bad estimate of test error
and so rss and r squared just are not
suitable for the task of choosing among
models with different numbers of
predictors